Hi guys, I'm Erik Voss. And we just got our first look at Spider-Man homecoming
Starring Captain America Civil War's Tom Holland as the New Young Spider-Man [now]
This is the third live-action version of Spider-Man that we've seen and I love a lot about the other two versions
But this might be the first one that really nails a character as he is in the comics
Maybe it's the fact that they got an actual kid for the part or that Marvel studios is
Co-producing this movie with Sony making it a true Marvel homecoming
Oh, that's why they called it that
I'm going to point out everything that you missed along with a few theories and predictions
Including some stuff in the other international trailer that was also released. Alright, let's get started
Spiderman: Sup guys wait a minute you guys on the real event just I can tell hope gives it away
Ok so after a few establishing shots of Peter Parker's neighborhood in Queens
New York we see this gang of thieves using an interesting device to crack open some atms
[so], what is this thing?
Some people are saying it could be based on Chitauri
Technology since this is the McU now and that is possible, but really based on shots from other parts in the trailer
It looks like Peter parker isn't the only one building advanced tech in this movie, and I just love Peter Parker's bugs bunny
What's up?
Doc pose intro here guys [spider-Man] sense of humor has always been a tricky thing to nail down like his jokes are kind of sarcastic
Not too serious
Meta style wait a minute you guys on the real event just I can tell hope gives it away
It was actually a main influence for deadpool except deadpool is obviously way edgier
So hearing Peter joke around about the [avengers] is exactly what we love about the character from the Marvel comics and speaking of the comics
[Spider-Man]
boiling a bank robbery by people wearing avengers mask seems to be inspired by seen from the ultimate Spider-Man comics though that scene had a
Batman mask in there. [I] also like to each of these [sixties], [Era] [avenger]
Masks this isn't just reference to the MCU and its current timeline
These are literal throwback to the old comics and as always no one wants to be hawkeye
and I'm just a
Helper and obviously Peter is wearing the new Spider-Man suit that he received from Tony stark and Captain America Civil war
[placing] most of the events in this movie after civil war and I'll come back to this, but let's move on
[listing] new top [know] you seen that before [know] what that skirt probably stop staring with for his creepy little
too late
Yes losers
So here we see how [spider-Man] homecoming will be a true
Teen comedy with Peter as a legit hoping nerd [an] outcast as opposed to these
stereotypical nerd versions and other movies where they only spent small parts of the movie in High school taking cool, Hollywood
Celebrities and making them nerds by giving them glasses now us nerds know what real nerds look like they look like you Tom
Holland minus the abs. We don't we don't do crunches, and I love the music that they use for this trailer
If [mGMt] [is] time to pretend which [you've] probably heard before it's been like a ton of TV shows and trailers
It's just a great youth anthem with the lyrics expressing the feeling of wanting to Repel against a mundane
preset Life and Explore life of adventure
Just like peter wants to buy joining. The [adventures]. We meet a few of the new characters in this section including ned leads
[who's] the character from Spider-Man comics he works with Peter at the Daily Bugle?
And then he later gets like brainwashed and framed by Hobgoblin
But in this movie net appears to just be like a high school friend and confidant Peter we also seized and I his character named
Michelle who we still don't know much about and then this girl that peter and [Dead] or creeply gawking at is
Lizallen she's from the earliest use of the comics
and unlike Mary Jane Watson and gwen Stacy Lizallen [and] Peter parker were never really a thing in fact apparently lizallen already did make a
Cameo in the first Tobey Maguire Spider-Man as this nerdy girl on the bus who won't let Peter sit next to [her] and notice how
[Liz] hanging a homecoming banner suggesting that the school's homecoming week will be the setting for the story
Makes [you] wonder future Spider-Man movies will turn this into a pattern like Spider-Man
Graduation or Spider-man in your teacher at least that was my high school experience
[no]
Moving on to become an adventure other like trials or an interview just don't do anything
I wouldn't do and definitely don't do anything. I wouldn't do
There's a little gray area in there, and that's where you want 30 [alright]
That's not a hug from [describing] the way [all] right kid. Good luck out there here
We see Peter parker with Tony
Stark who lays out the small range of hero jobs that peters allowed to take on [like] don't step on starks turf
But also don't do anything bad either just basically stick to saving a few [atms]
I guess this also kind of hints when this movie takes place
Based on the conversation and the fact that stark is dropping peter off this seems to be
Taking place after the airport battle and civil war [making] me think that the beginning of this movie is going to be like
additional clips from the Battle from Peters [Point-of-view] leading to this abrupt goodbye and Peter longing to swing back in the action [at] the
International trailer confirms this sequence a little bit further with a few extra
Lines with Peter learning that he gets to keep the suit and start emphasizing that peter is not an adventure also like Peter shirt here
The physics is theoretical, but the fun is real
It seems like he's gonna be wearing a few different dorky science shirts, and there's a fun connection about another one later
So let's move on
Listen I know school sucks. You still with us. Yeah. Yeah, [I] know you want to save the world
You're not ready
Here's a spider-man. No not now. This is just a costume this [trip]
Ok so a few interesting things here first is Peter walks through high School hall
There's a mural in the background and you can see howard stark among a collage of science and technology
And then and [Peter's] classroom Bruce Banners photo is placed next to other notable
Scientists also check out this video that peter watches of himself as he takes down and man that we saw in Civil war the angle
Of the shot is from the ground level as it rolls safely past the action now we know from that scene with [Tony] [stark] [its]
Award that peter likes to set up cameras to record himself in action
so [I'm] thinking that this might be taken from like a
gopro that
He set up on Aruba or something like that, and if you look closely you can see Tony rebel
[Lori]
Who was confirmed to play flash Thompson back at comic-con [turn] around giving Peter a stink-eye in the scene and then notice this?
Explosion on the street here first we see a car blow up followed by a corner store next to it
So what's going on here [today]?
Guys don't just explode cards do sometimes now my cSI [train] analysis suggests that some projectile a missile perhaps
Or maybe just like a beam of energy blasts through the car and explodes inside the store
And it seems like nothing this destructive has happened in [Peters] neighborhood before
Making this the event that raises the stakes in the story by bringing the danger to his home a homecoming of danger
Yeah, and then we see peters bedroom, or maybe this is [ned] bedroom
We're not really sure it's filled with Star Wars easter eggs first
We see the 80 or at if you're wrong which is fun
Considering peter reference specifically when he used the same method to bring down and man
Also, named drops [the] Lego death star and if you look closely you can see vintage star Wars action figures on the shelf and now
That both marvel and star wars are owned by Disney. We can expect to see lots more of these kinds of crossovers. Let's move on
See close to the brown
Stay out of trouble
This section gives us our first look at Michael Keaton has birdman
I mean the vulture aka [Adrian] [toumus] the vulture is one of the main Spider-Man villains
He's part of the sinister six
And fun facts same rainy initially wanted him to be the villain in the third Spider-Man movie instead of Venom
He's an old man who created a suit that lets [them] fly and give some super strength and at one point
He steals Spider-Man's youth and the vulture suit looks pretty [freaking] cool in this movie
It almost looks like he has stark style
repulsors to help them hover and balance
And I love these tiny green lights [is] the eyes look very very creepy
And it's rumored that Michael chernus is the tinker will be behind a lot of this mysterious [texts] that we see this movie though
He doesn't appear in this trailer
And it seems like one of the big action scenes in this movie will take place at the Washington monument in Washington DC
And it's hard to tell exactly what's going on the entity makes
It look like the vultures shattering this class, but that was from a different location
This is the observation deck of the Washington monument really what I think is happening here
is this is a separate scene of the
Elevator of the Washington monument being attacked in this class belongs to the top floor of the elevator shaft
and we see a lot of other clips later in the trailer with [Liz] in the elevator and
Spider-Man holding onto someone who's falling out of it who in the international trailer shows us
It's lives in this cloud of dust coming out of the base of the monument could be that elevator crashing into the bottom level
So my guess is this is all part of a rescue sequence kind of similar to that Brooklyn bridge rescue in the first Spider-Man movie
But relocated to the Washington monument
Perhaps as a reference to the battle and road to Civil war let's move on
Forget the flying monster guy there are people who handle this [ourselves] [can] treat me like a doll is high
But you are a kid. [this] is my chance to prove myself
What is going on with you? I'm really sorry so busy [and] slam
Don't mess with kill you and everybody blow
Ok so here. We see peter back with stark in Avengers headquarter, and it's not exactly clear. Why Peter is here
I've been to ask stark for help and taking on the vulture
Now some people are saying it could be similar to a storyline in the comics like when Peter breaks into the fantastic four
headquarters and hopes of gaining the security of being part of a super team
Also like this little easter egg here with Peter wearing the same shirt that we saw pepper [potts] wearing an iron
Man 3 we also see this epic shot a [spider] [man] jumping off just the tip of the Washington monument
and I love everything about this from them knowing that the
Capstone of the Washington monument is made from pure aluminum to this new modification of the Spider-Man Suit Web Wings spidey gliders
net weaknesses
I don't know they let him glide like a flying squirrel and those look like they could be a throwback to the original Steve
Ditko design a [Spider-Man] which had this weird pointless webbing between the arms and torso ok so if you look closely at this section
You'll find quick cameos by Martin [starr] who plays the teacher and chaperone to the students as well as logan Marshall-Green
And Donald glover who seem like they might be playing bad guys
So you know a lot of people were thinking that dog lover being in this movie might?
Mean that we might see some connection to Miles Morales Spider-Man
I don't know if that's gonna happen and they seem to be testing some more interesting looking tech which takes the form of a
Hand and a powerful blast of some kind and I'm thinking this could be what lit up that car in corner store that we saw
earlier in the trailer
But a lot of people are saying that logan Marshall-green outfit here looks Kinda like the [leak] set photos of the shocker
But it seems more likely that became woodbine is going to be the shocker in this movie
We do see him in the international trailer
Holding and are mounted weapon with more of an electric charge kind of effect here
And his clothes are kind of yellow as well
And that seems to be from the same scene is when [Spiderman] gets slammed around a school bus yard if you look closely here [peter]
is wearing an older version of his suit when he had before start gave him the upgrade so either this is a
Flashback from before Civil war or more likely Peter does something to lose the suit like start
Confiscating it after peter tries to overstep his bounds and Peter's wearing that same older costume in this shot of him looking roughed up on
the Beach in this fight with the vulture so my guess is that this isn't a
Flashback [or] rather something that happens in the middle of the movie and we hear this menacing line from the vulture here?
kill you
And everybody involved
Meanwhile the international trailer offers a little more insight into his character with this line world's changing boys
Time we change to and that makes the vulture sound like perhaps the leader of a group of bad guys who are
Reacting to a world of superheroes and super tech using their own advanced [task] for evil purposes and before we move on
There's a quick shot of this massive blast coming out of the staten island Ferry and it looks like the vultures responsible
But I'll talk more about this after this final section
[yeah], [yeah]
[yeah]
[ok] whatever that blast was looks like a tour of this ferry in half because
Spider-Man is now using this webbing to hold it together and this shot reminds me so much of that awesome
[seen] Spider-Man 2 with spider-man stretching himself to a breaking point to stop the train and if you look closely
You can see the statue of Liberty in the background here
Yeah, this trailer is weirdly heavy on distinctly Patriotic landmarks, and this final shot is just great
Not only are we gonna get some scenes between Peter Parker and Tony stark?
Spider-Man and Iron man are actually [going] [to] swoop in action together. I honestly never thought
I would see this image in a movie now. If you're really a nerd stuff like this
You should definitely sign up with Luke grades
Loot Crate is a monthly subscription
Box service that hooks you up with a bunch of awesome gear from all the nerdy stuff that we cover on this channel including
All Marvel comics
And you can sign up right now by going to [look] [great] calm
Rock stars to each month has a theme and the theme for the box that just arrived is magical, so let's take a look
[yeah]
So that was november's box [in] [December's] theme is
Revolution and you can get that by signing up on the nineteenth of the month by 9PM [Pacific]
It's less than twenty dollars a month and if you use our promo code
[rockstars] you'll get ten percent off and we have new Rock stars are doing a bonus giveaway
We're gonna have a chance to win this box that [had] just opened
And the loot where that I just open plus the cool giveaway that we gave our previous lucky winners just sign up for loot crate
right now at Luke rate Com
Rock stars [to] then tweeted us to let us know that you did and what you're most excited about for Spider-Man
Homecoming ok that's it
Thanks for watching and let me know what you think in the comments
And of course please hit like and subscribe to new Rock stars and share this video with your friends you can also contribute to us
on Patreon
Thank you so much to all of our current donors you guys are the best if you are currently a patron we love your support
you can hit me up on Twitter at [Yvonne's] with any thoughts or
Predictions are theories you have about Spider-Man homecoming can also follow new Rock stars on Twitter at new Rock stars [right]? Thanks for watching
[yeah]